you choreographed a YouTube video that
went viral viral receiving 4 million
views in 2016.
um you were 15.
and then later that year
he choreographed another YouTube video
for Run the World which I think is
Beyonce yeah it doesn't say here
received 8 million views
how the hell what
there's a lot of build up there's a lot
of dramatic thoughts well I'm just like
I I look because I think I look at 15
and I'm like
you know I'm like oh my god what
happened in my pants you know oh my God
what am I doing uh I didn't know what I
was 15. I had no maturity I didn't I was
just like no brain your frontal cortex
server sorry it's not formed
you don't think as the things you think
of later and but you're moving at 15 and
you're did you what how did that happen
I mean how did you say this is what I'm
gonna do is it was your idea this is
what happened so my friend Taylor and I
you're Swift no I wish
love her
my friend Taylor and I we had been
working with a choreographer named
Janelle genestra and we started we had
this idea where like there's so many
Dance videos out there where people are
you know we're in class it started
that's when all the Social Media stuff
kind of started pumping around like when
I was like 13 everyone was filming their
classes now putting them up on YouTube
and it was just like gaining a lot of
traction and
our choreographer Janelle and Taylor and
I were like okay how could we make this
different and she was like why don't we
start doing dance concept videos let's
tell a story through dance and I'm like
that's a great idea let's do it let's
have a message behind each one and let's
go for it and so the first one we did
it was really just for fun the two of us
we called ourselves the fraternal twins
uh we kind of looked a little bit
similar and she did she needed less
anesthesia
[Music]
all right go ahead go on
and
we filmed the first one and we it was to
IDF with you and
um I don't Frick with you
oh so you could
Stop Printing that [__] but you can't
say it huh
that is I grew up dancing to I look back
at like videos on YouTube when I was
like 12 dancing to the most like crazy
music but at that time in dance like I
never listened to the lyrics because
every move for us is on the Beats so I
look back at like videos about 12
dancing to the most like insane songs
and I'm like no wonder in the comments
people are like why do you have a 12
year old dancing to this
makes sense sometimes I've seen stuff
like that I'm like they're letting their
kids listen to this music yes well guess
what it was the same thing when I was
younger I was listening to two Live Crew
everybody say hey I won't say it but
they said some gnarly [__] and uh
listening to NWA
Frick the police coming down with
authority
it's totally it and I would beat box hey
[Music]
um
okay
oh all right
um so then we did this the one for
Beyonce Run the World and that one was
just about women empowerment and that
was one of my favorite ones just the
message behind it and it just we went to
sleep and I swear it was like we woke up
and there was like three million views
and we were like
wait what like what but how do people
even like
I put some funny ass stuff up yeah but
I'm like thank you yeah but I'm like
this is funny
and for some reason I just don't I guess
I don't have did you already have a lot
of followers from the first video we
kind of already had like a fan base that
one kind of grew over time like within a
week it was just like whoa this is crazy
and like Good Morning America and we
have these people reaching out to us to
like come on the show and we're like
wait what this is just nuts did you get
any money for all the views so it wasn't
on my channel
um split it with you well I actually
don't know if those videos were
monetized because 4 million get you some
money these days yeah four million you
probably would have gotten fifteen
thousand dollars twenty thousand dollars
for that video Yeah crazy right it is
did Beyonce call you or message you she
posted us on Twitter
and like put up our video and I think
that's how that one kind of sparked she
loved it she sent it out and boom yeah
and that started getting you some
attention yeah and that's kind of you're
dancing I need to watch this we need to
go watch this yeah are you are you great
in this
is it pretty cool I yeah you should
watch it it's very it's very funny
because people are always like Larson
you're this very like
you know soft-spoken individual yeah
kind of just like you know and then you
do you dance and it's like this Beast
comes out it's like fire we don't even
recognize you I'm like yeah you know
that's where that passion comes out yeah